it is september 20th 2022 and you're
watching the code report it's time to
reset the counter yet again it's been
zero days since a new javascript
framework has been released the highly
anticipated quick framework built by a
dream team of developers just hit beta
yesterday now before you go and change
the channel this isn't just another
average five inch framework it brings an
entirely new rendering paradigm to the
table called resumability which totally
eliminates the need for hydration the
technique used by almost every meta
framework today to make server rendered
websites fully interactive to understand
what makes quick special we first need
to understand the problem with the
current generation of frameworks the key
to a perfect lighthouse performance
score is to use less javascript google
did some science and found that making a
website 20 faster results in ten percent
more conversions if your website makes a
thousand dollars a year that could be
like ten dollars you're leaving on the
table the catch-22 of web development is
that in order to implement the features
your customers want you need more
javascript but in order to make your
site fast you need less javascript like
in next.js for example you start with
about 70 kilobytes of javascript out of
the gate thanks to react-dom you'll then
add at least a couple hundred more
kilobytes to that with your own
application code that will scale of
based on how much application code you
have on the page that's because on the
initial page load the framework needs to
hydrate the dom and rebuild or bootstrap
the entire component tree from the
ground up it's kind of like watching a
movie that can't be paused if you need
to restart the application by hitting
the refresh button in the browser it
needs to re-execute all the javascript
from the beginning to get back to where
it was refresh damp refresh damn
frameworks like astro have recognized
this problem which uses a technique
called partial hydration to selectively
hydrate the dom but quick cuts out
hydration altogether like it's just not
even necessary it delivers html that's
instantly interactive that means in
theory you should be able to achieve a
perfect lighthouse performance score no
matter how big and complex your
javascript code base is that sounds too
good to be true so how is it even
possible the key innovation here is that
a quick app can be fully serialized as
html in other words at any moment you
can hit the pause button and capture all
the data and closures in the application
and represent it all as an html string
that's huge for server-side rendering
because by the time that html gets to
the browser it can just pick up where
the server left off without needing to
execute any javascript at all and that's
why they coined the term resumability
now the other thing that makes this
magic possible is lazy loading which is
built in as a primitive part of the
framework to understand it let's look at
some code at first glance it looks like
a react app that uses functional
components and jsx but what's the deal
with this dollar sign it actually
represents a lazy loaded boundary and
what you'll find is that everything is
lazy loaded and that even includes
things like event handlers that close
over the state of the application that's
kind of crazy because how does this
chunk of javascript know the state of
the application if it's lazy loaded if
we look at the html we can see this
event handler is serialized directly
into the code now if we open the network
tab we'll find zero javascript on the
initial page load you'll notice that
that javascript is not actually loaded
until we click the button it contains
the code we want to execute and also has
access to the lexical environment to
update state that might be shared by
other components which itself comes from
another lazy loaded chunk the takeaway
here is that you don't actually need to
load any javascript until the user
interacts with the ui if we go ahead and
build the application which is powered
by veet you'll notice we get a ton of
tiny chunks less than one kilobyte each
instead of a single massive bundle and
because of that quick can scale
infinitely to as much javascript as your
heart desires
[Music]
that's enough
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one